so President Trump is getting rid of the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program President Obama's executive
amnesty sort of or maybes not or what's
he gonna do next and what's everybody
yelling about we will explain all of it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show so much daca your head will spin
we'll go through all aspects of the
deferred action on childhood arrivals
program where everybody stands why is
everybody going nuts when they basically
all agree on policy and why is it that
Republicans are so terrible at
everything we'll explain all things all
things will be clear by the end of
today's show plus an amazing story
harkening back to the Obama
administration they actually used the
Holocaust Memorial Museum as a
propaganda outfit I will explain all of
this but first I want to say hello to
our sponsors over at blinds.com so one
thing you don't think about a lot when
you look around your house is how crappy
your blinds look believe me your plants
look like garbage
that's why you need blinds calm because
the fact is that if you don't want your
blinds to look like something out of the
wire then it is necessary that you go
over to blinds calm and you check out
all of their great materials what you do
is you measure the window you send their
measurements into blinds calm and they
send you the blinds and then if they're
actually the wrong size they remake it
they make it right for free right I mean
that's an amazing deal you screw up and
they still fix it for you
they send you free samples to make sure
that everything looks as good in person
as it does on line they have consultants
who can help you with a free design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms and again
if you screw it up with the measurements
or the or the color or the size they
will read make your blinds for free
which is pretty amazing stuff they've
made it super easy for you right now for
a limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code bed
blinds Comm promo code ban nothing looks
cleaner than a nice set of lines in and
the blinds that they've got are not just
you know the the old-fashioned idiotic
like aluminum blinds I've got faux wood
blinds and cellular shades and roller
shades like all the things that you see
in the fancy houses that's what they
have over a blinds.com
20% off everything at blinds calm when
you use the promo code Ben again
blinds.com promo code Ben rules and
restrictions apply use that promo code
bands that they know that we sent you as
well so yesterday
of course the big news was president the
president Trump announces that President
Obama's deferred action on childhood
arrivals program is dead or is it or
maybe not or kind of but not really
that's that's sort of what this was so
remember all the people who were in the
ann coulter in trump we trust camp they
thought that this was going to be like
Trump's number one thing he was gonna
come in he was gonna deport a bunch of
illegal immigrants he was gonna get move
out the parents who's gonna take the
kids he's gonna dump them all so there
was going to be mass deportations there
was going to be a deportation squad a
deportation force like this is what a
lot of people who are on the Trump train
from the very beginning thought in fact
remember back to the campaign there's a
revisionist history going on now where a
lot of people say well Trump was always
soft on immigration are you insane
I was here every day doing play-by-play
for the campaign one of the things that
Trump did to great effect was bashed the
living hell out of people like Ted Cruz
who's very strong and immigration has
not strong enough on immigration if you
recall Donald Trump basically took Marco
Rubio's head stuck it in the toilet and
then sat on it over the issue of
immigration and the gang of eight bill
the idea was that you could never give
amnesty to anyone well now Trump comes
along seven months into his
administration instead of getting rid of
daca on day one President Obama's
executive amnesty on day one he waited
for seven months and then he had Jeff
Sessions come out and say that this is
being rescinded because it's illegal
here was Jeff Sessions his Attorney
General it shows you how uncomfortable
Trump is with the actual policy here
that he sends out sessions if Trump were
really comfortable he'd go out and
announce it himself he did with the
plant in the Paris climate change
agreement if I recall correctly that is
not what happened here here is Jeff
Sessions the reason the Jeff Sessions
stuck around by the way you remember
like a month ago when Donald Trump was
just humiliating sessions on a daily
basis there's only six weeks ago okay
time has stopped we're actually moving
backwards in time we've reached 88 miles
per hour in the political sphere and
we're back in 1955 trying to make sure
that Marty's mom and dad get together
but time is moving so slowly it was only
like six weeks ago that Jeff Sessions is
being attacked by President Trump as
incompetent and terrible and horrible
well Jeff Sessions stuck around because
this is the only thing Jeff Sessions
cares about ok the illegal immigration
issue is one of Jeff Sessions big things
I know this because I was at a drinking
session in late night drinking session
between Ann Coulter Jeff Sessions and
Stephen Miller as like two years ago
three years ago maybe yes three years
ago and Jeff Sessions
and Steven Miller and Ann Coulter were
all hot and heavy over what they were
going to do to restrict immigration so
this is Jeff Sessions thing okay he
loves this so here is Jeff Sessions
yesterday look how happy he looks for
the first time in months he really looks
truly happy with what he's doing here
the program known as daca that was
effectuated under the obama
administration is being rescinded the
daca program was implemented in 2012 and
essentially provided a legal status for
recipients for a renewable two-year term
worker authorization and other benefits
including participation in the Social
Security program to 800,000 mostly adult
illegal aliens okay so he's very happy
about all of this now he's right that
this is unconstitutional okay it was
being struck down by the courts this is
the weird thing if Trump had just waited
for about three weeks they're a bunch of
courts that we're gonna strike down
Obama's executive amnesty and then he
wouldn't have to do anything but he
jumped the gun and announced instead
that he's getting rid of daca and then
throwing it over to Congress so let's
start with I got a couple emails
yesterday people wanted to know why is
daca unconstitutional the reason the tax
is unconstitutional is because the
President and the Department of Justice
do you have prosecutorial discretion
okay they can just decide who they want
to prosecute and who they don't want to
prosecute it does raise questions about
a legality when you are just absolving
friends and family but they're allowed
to do that they do a prosecutorial
discretion that's not really the issue
here the issue is that Obama went
further than that under daca all these
people were not just said it wasn't just
said they're not gonna be prosecuted for
being here illegally they're actually
handed work papers okay so the Obama
administration without legislative
approval went ahead and did all of this
that is a is a usurpation of legislative
authority the legislature is given the
responsibility to decide whether to give
amnesty and work papers whether people
should be here legally and the executive
branch basically decided to overthrow
all that that's why it's
unconstitutional so session says we're
gonna rescind daca and he's obviously
very happy about it
Trump however has different thoughts
Trump is split on this because Trump on
the one hand says I won't know these
people out on the other hand he also
says I want all these people in so here
is Trump yesterday literally yesterday
saying he has great love for the
dreamers
have a great life for the folks we're
talking about a great love for them and
people think in terms of children but
they're really young adults I have a
love for these people and hopefully now
Congress will be able to help them and
do it properly and I can tell you and
speaking to members of Congress they
want to be able to do something and do
it right and really we have no choice we
have to be able to do something and I
think it's going to work out very well
and long term it's going to be the right
solution okay we have no choice is
always trumpian code for I'm not sure I
really wanted to do this but we have to
do it right this is this is this is what
he's saying here now here's the thing
that's funny
if Trump really the left is going nuts
over this of course because if he has a
great heart for these people then why is
he just making them why is he exposing
them to possible deportation the answer
would be that he wants his actual answer
on what Trump is actually saying here is
not that he wants to get rid of daca
he's saying I want akka to be permanent
I want the legislature to actually make
daca permanent okay so he's actually
ramming through Obama's executive
amnesty as legislation something Obama
couldn't do with the Republican Congress
Trump wants to do with the Republican
Congress okay this is Trump's Nixon in
China moment right Nixon campaign in
1968 in 1972 has a very anti-communist
guy and then he travels to China and
quote-unquote opens China that's what
Trump is doing here he campaigned as a
very anti-illegal immigrant guy and here
he is now saying he wants the
legislature I can make no mistake this
is what he is doing he is announcing
publicly that he wants Congress to make
Obama's executive amnesty permanent
that's what he's saying here and in case
he wasn't clear enough here is what he
tweeted yesterday he tweeted this threat
quote Congress now has six months to
legalize daca something the Obama
administration was unable to do if they
can't I will revisit this issue okay
what he's saying here is he wants daca
to be permanent he just wants Congress
to do it he doesn't want to be blamed
for doing it he wants Congress to do it
and what's amazing about this is that
the entire threat here let's say that
your Republican Congress person and
you're looking at your base and your
base really does not want you to
enshrine daca your base hates daca not
because of the unconstitutionality issue
they hate it mostly because they don't
want 800,000 so-called dreamers to be in
the country illegally they want some of
these people deported
so you're a Republican Congress person
and here
Trump sponsoring downtown your office
and he says I want you to pass this and
you say well I can't because then I'll
get primary mr. president are you gonna
protect me from primary and Trump sort
of just hides behind the curtain Trump's
not gonna protect any of these
Republican Congress people from being
primaried which is why you're seeing
Paul Ryan say I'm not gonna push any
bill at all unless Trump explicitly
endorses it because he doesn't want
because Trump is set up this weird
situation where all the Trump people are
loyal to Trump but Trump is now pushing
a policy that is precisely the reverse
of what he's pushing during the campaign
I mean let's be frank about this if
we're gonna be honest about what Trump
is doing here what he's doing here is
backtracking on a key campaign promise
this is not just me saying it it's Ann
Coulter saying it okay Ann Coulter was
the biggest trump booster in this
election cycle BarNone okay here is what
she said on Twitter she said that's
great Sarah Huckabee Sanders says Trump
wants comprehensive immigration reform
exactly what he used to denounce she
said Trump's landmark election winning
immigration speech 831 16 enforcement
first we can't even discuss amnesty
until we have a wall weird how Sarah
Huckabee Sanders Trump spokesperson
obsessively attacks Congress Trump's are
not gonna get out of betraying voters on
the wall by blaming Congress right so
she's absolutely hammering president
Trump over all of this and if you are
intellectually honest and you thought
that Trump was going to actually get rid
of daca you should be hammering him too
because the fact is what he is now
calling for is keeping Jaca and here was
the threat that he was going to use
right the threat that he was going to
use against his homeland Republican
Congress people wasn't I need you to
pass this bill or I'm in a primary you
it was if you don't pass this bill then
I am going to go after all 800,000
illegal immigrants and then the
Republican Party will become very
unpopular so you pass the bill you take
the you take the responsibility I'll
reluctantly sign it and that will be the
way that we worked this thing right
that's the way that Trump wants to work
it the way Trump wants to work it is he
wants Congress to pass executive amnesty
he wants to say I had no choice but to
sign it
they had wall funding right that's what
he wants to say and then he wants to
turn around and blame Congress for
everything and Congress is saying I
don't want to do that but Trump's entire
threats get Congress to do that is that
he's going to be the bad guy right he's
gonna step in and start deporting people
but in this tweet he says he's not going
to do that in this tweet he gives away
every bit of leverage he has
in this suite he says if they don't pass
deca
I will revisit the issue meaning maybe
I'll leave death had in place after all
maybe this is all fake
great maybe I'm pretending here so what
does this really say that says the Trump
doesn't want to get rid of daca okay
Trump was doing something that he thinks
is going to be just sort of enough
facade to fake out his base but it's not
really a in actual policy okay it's not
an actual policy of changing immigration
policy his entire administration is on
the same page here Sarah Huckabee
Sanders says this is not cold-hearted
he's upholding the law but it's not
cold-hearted it's not cold-hearted for
the President to uphold the law we're a
nation of law and order and the day that
we start to ignore the fact that we are
that then we throw away everything that
gives these people a reason to want to
come to our country if we stop becoming
the country that we were envisioned to
be then we throw away what makes us
special which makes America unique this
president's not willing to do that the
previous administration was this one
isn't but we want to have real solutions
we want to have laws that that address
these problems but it's Congress's job
to legislate not the president's we
actually and we actually want to uphold
the Constitution and I think people
across this country should be
celebrating the fact that they have a
president that is standing up and
upholding the Constitution as he was
elected to this bench again that doesn't
wash because he's been calling on
Congress to pass exactly the same policy
that he's rejecting at the executive
level so even if I agree with the
constitutional argument which I do I
don't understand why Trump's base is not
upset with him if he is going to push
Congress into basically an amnesty
program that he was elected to stop and
he was elected to stop remember this is
the same Republican Party that rejected
President Bush's amnesty program this is
Marco Rubio for the gang of eight stuff
so this notion that Trump can push it
and get away with it would be an amazing
amazing shifting of the goalposts by a
lot of trumps fans if that's indeed what
happens now what this means is that
there's a conflict between left and
right over nothing
they basically agree on policy and I'll
explain about that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron so blue
apron is the best way to build found and
family bonds well eating healthy instead
of you going out to a restaurant and
eating something that they lard it up
with salt and fat instead of you going
out to a restaurant and having to worry
about your small children climbing up
the walls as I do so often instead of
doing that instead you can have blue
apron ship these ingredients directly to
your home they send you the recipe they
send you the ingredients prepackaged
absolutely fresh you make it yourself
you cook at home and you're more likely
to cook if you do this at home because
instead of you just going out to the
grocery store buying a bunch of
groceries you don't know what you're
gonna use it for later and then you
throw away half the groceries you buy
instead blue apron sends you the exact
recipes with the exact ingredients to
your house you cook it yourself more it
means that you're going to cook more
often plus it's restaurant quality
restaurant great dishes stuff that you
can get better at that's better at home
than it is at a restaurant even and now
you're spending under $10 per person for
a delicious meal let me just read you
some of the some of the dishes that you
are going to be making in your home with
blue apron you're gonna be making
skillet vegetable chili with cornmeal
and cheddar drop biscuits garlic butter
shrimp and corn with green bean salad
and roasted purple tomatoes some are
vegetable and egg paninis with Calabrian
Calabrian chili mayonnaise and caprese
salad I mean these are dishes so
sophisticated I cannot even pronounce
them okay this is like restaurant stuff
this is the kind of stuff where you go
to a restaurant and ask the waiter what
it even means but you are going to be
the person who's making it in your home
with your family it's a lot of fun I
really enjoy cooking with my kids you'll
enjoy it too except you'll do it way
better than I will over at blue apron
they're offering 30-minute meals right
now these meals are made with the same
flavor and farm-fresh ingredients you
know and love they're ready in 30
minutes or less you can check out this
week's menu by the way the menus never
repeat check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free with
free shipping by going to blue apron
calm blue apron calm the recipes are not
repeated within a year so you're never
gonna get bored here it's not gonna be
like okay oh my god not spaghetti again
every freaking Tuesday these things
don't repeat unless you want them to
repeat your first three meals for free
with free shipping at blue aprons Comm /
Shapiro that's blue aprons com
/ Shapiro's blue apron is a better way
to cook a healthier way to cook a less
expensive way to cook
it tastes better than the stuff that
you're going to get at a restaurant okay
so here's the amazing thing
Democrats and Republicans apparently
agree on the dreamers okay Trump agrees
that he wants them to stay the
Republicans agree that they want them to
stay the Democrats agree that they want
them to stay so naturally that means
that they're clubbing each other in the
head with baseball bat because that's
how our politics works now the way
politics works is that people don't
disagree on anything but they have to
invest their politics with a deeper
meaning and so they people living crap
out of each other every single day over
virtually nothing understand something
the Democrats agree with Trump on daca
Trump agrees with the Democrats on daca
he wants Congress to pass daca okay the
idea that there's any broad disagreement
here is insane but that's not the way
this is being paint painted so President
Obama immediately decides to come back
out of the woodwork and bug everyone he
we just couldn't get rid of him he goes
on Facebook and he decides that he has
to defend his executive amnesty here's
what he says he says quote immigration
can be a controversial topic we all want
safe secure borders and a dynamic
economy and people of goodwill can have
illegitimate disagreements about how to
fix our immigration system so that
everybody plays by the rules but that's
not what the action the White House took
tonight is about this is about young
people who grew up in America these
dreamers are Americans in their hearts
in their minds in every single way but
one on paper they're brought to this
country by the parents sometimes even as
infants they may not know what country
beside ours they might not even know a
language besides English over the years
politicians both parties have worked to
write legislation they would have told
these young people our young people that
if your parents brought you here as a
child if you've been here a certain
number of years and if you're willing to
go to college or serve in our military
you get a chance to stay earn your
citizenship for yours I ask Congress to
send me such a bill that bill never came
and he goes on and he calls Trump cruel
right he says it's cruel what if our
kids science teacher or our friendly
neighbor turns out to be a dreamer where
are we supposed to send her to a country
she doesn't know or remember with a
language she may not even speak get this
notion that if you were brought here as
a child
you therefore must stay because we have
a responsibility to you this has never
made sense to me it just thought it's
not a good argument it's like saying
your parents embezzled so you get to
keep the cash okay it may hurt you it's
not your fault your parents
your file your parent was a criminal but
we all live with the legacy of things
that our parents did that we're wrong
it's the country's decision as to
whether people should stay or not this
is why I've always thought so weird that
when it comes to immigration we always
treat people as a class I'm not a big
fan of treating people as members of a
class as you know right I know the left
likes doing this right you're Hispanic
or you're black you're an illegal
immigrant you're a Jew you're a woman I
like treating people as individuals so
this seems to me as though we should
approach illegal immigrants in the same
case-by-case way that we approach people
who are trying to come here legally
and when my father in law came to the
United States with his wife legally he
had to go through a rigorous process he
had to show that he was employed he had
to show that it wasn't a male welfare he
had to show that he was going to that he
was going to be employed by this
employer for a certain period of time I
had to have a green car right he had to
go through this long process took my
wife 10 15 years to get citizenship okay
that seems to me the same way that we
should treat dreamers that just because
you were here from the time that you
were two let's say just because you were
here from the time you were two that
doesn't mean that you are automatically
a citizen and that means that the
country has the ability to make the
decision as to whether you are detriment
or benefit to the country or not so
that's you it seems to me we should be
approaching this on an individual level
but the temptation for Democrats is
always to treat everybody as a class and
then say that if you want to get rid of
some members of the class you hate the
entire class you understand how this
logic works this is how Democrats
operate what they do is they say all
black people are victims then you say
well that's not true some black people
are not victims they say you hate black
people don't you understand you hate
them that's the reason you're targeting
black people right now is cuz you hate
them these are all black people are
victims then they do the same thing with
with Hispanics and illegal immigrants
they say well all of these dreamers are
wonderful people who deserve to stay see
well some of them probably are many of
them probably are but some of them
probably are not and Democrats say how
dare you attack the dreamers how dare
you attack them I mean there are there
are very few dreamers who are very bad
people how dare you say some of them
should go how dare you say we should
screen them how dare you say we should
treat them as individuals that means the
hate the entire class you must be a
racist and this is the routine that
Obama is pulling today
he says the action taken today isn't
required legally it's a political
decision and a moral question okay first
of all it was required legally but Trump
cut his own case for why it was required
legally by waiting seven months to do it
it's also weird that if you say it's
unconstitutional that you're saying the
in six months you may reimplemented so
the Trump has a case but he's undercut
his own case and then Obama continues he
says whatever concerns or complaints
Americans may have about immigration in
general we shouldn't threaten the future
of this group of young people who are
here through no fault of their own who
posed no threat or not taking away
anything from the rest of us I'm very
sick of this argument again the no-fault
through no fault of their own routine is
really a bad argument okay there are a
lot of people who we were like the vast
majority of criminals are criminals
technically through no fault of their
own not the vast majority but a
significant minority of criminals are
people who maybe grew up in bad
circumstances without any sense of
morality and they make decisions because
they're stupid and now we put them in
jail okay is that their fault you know
there's a contingent default this is not
quite the same thing I mean if you're
born in the United States obviously you
have no control over the circumstances
of your birth but I mean I would like to
apply the same logic to people who are
wealthy right why is it the people who
are born into wealthy families are
supposed to pay all of their estate tax
right they're supposed to have all their
money given away what are they born rich
through some fault of their own was that
their fault like we can't determine
where we're born but we can determine
where we go from there
which is why I think we should offer a
pathway to citizenship for dreamers who
we think ought to stay in the same way
that legal immigrants ought to stay but
they ought to go to the back of the line
he says this con this action is contrary
to our spirit and it's common sense
business leaders faith leaders
economists Americans of all political
stripes called on the administration not
to do what it did today so you know
Obama's going nuts and this is pretty
common you're seeing that you're seeing
all the Democrats lose their minds
Andrew Mitchell she comes out from MSNBC
and she says Jeff Sessions used the word
illegal aliens that's just offensive
it's just terrible it also denied jobs
to hundreds of thousands of Americans by
allowing those same illegal aliens to
take those jobs
to say nothing of his use of the word
illegal aliens which is offensive to a
lot of people and not correct but
Michael the fact is I don't know what
he's talking about when he talks about
the border no what this has nothing to
do with the border
oh no we certainly that's certainly the
correct term I mean the illegal alien
just means a person who came here
illegally so but again the idea here is
that you're a racist if you suggest that
that we have to control our borders Joy
Behar says the same thing she says it's
racist it's racist I mean if the Trump
administration is all about jobs a lot
of them employ people also by the way
but if they're all about jobs and and
saving money and having money in the
United States then why would you then
get rid of people y24
that's the lie that he's not about that
because none of these kids or people who
ever thought whatever ages they are are
from Sweden or Norway they're all from
these brown so-called brown country
brown people who are not white non-white
people so this racism involved here and
what are they just admitted okay the
idea by the way
that all dreamers are from Mexico is
just not true okay the fact is the
dreamers are from a wide variety of
countries apparently there are 800,000
undocumented immigrants who are given a
daca
referral here they are by top countries
of origin okay you ready El Salvador's
number one at about 28,000 Guatemala is
number two hunters is number three
Peru's number four then South Korea okay
so about 72 hundred seventy three
hundred members of the dreamer community
who are South Korean okay the
Philippines is on this list at five
thousand India has 3,000 people on this
list okay there there are a lot of
people from South and Latin America but
that's because we have a contiguous
continent with them but the idea that it
is only people who are from countries
that are that are south of the border
that's not technically true it's just
not technically true but again the idea
is that Trump is a racist if he wants to
enforce the border but the problem is
Trump doesn't even want to enforce the
border okay that's the thing that's
amazing Trump isn't even Inc he's not
even interested in supporting all these
people and I'm going to explain why I
think a lot of people are gonna go along
with this regardless and it just
demonstrates why partisanship has now
taken a front seat over good policy on
both sides we'll get to that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at frame bridge
so you have a big poster and you want to
frame it you go to over to Aaron
Brothers and in and you walk in and they
tell you it's gonna cost you 300 bucks
to get a nice custom poster frame okay
that's not how it's supposed to work go
over to frame bridge calm you upload
your photo from your computer or
directly from your Instagram feed or if
you have a physical item they will send
you prepaid packaging you can mail it in
for free you can preview your photo
online in any frame style choose your
favorite get free help from their
talented designers and then they will
custom frame or item in days not weeks
or months deliver your finished piece
directly to your door ready to hang
instead of the hundreds you pay at a
framing store their prices start at 39
bucks all shipping is free and my
listeners get 15% off their first order
at frame bridge comm when they use my
promo code Shapiro and by the way they
have a happiness guarantee if you earn a
hundred percent satisfied with your
piece they will make it right
frame bridge comm we've used them for
family photos it really is terrific it's
very user friendly it's great because
you know normally if you went over to
some frame store you'd have to print out
the photo instead you can just upload
the photos directly to frame bridge they
print them out they put them in the
frame for you which is awesome go over
to frame bridge comm use promo code
Shapiro saved that additional 15% off
your first order
that's frame bridge comm promo code
Shapiro again frame bridge comm promo
code Shapiro so the left is going nuts
over this even though they know it's
Kabuki theater why are the left going
nuts over this even though they know
it's Kabuki theater because they're
trying to damage Trump even though
Trump's actual intent here is to do the
same thing that they want and some of
this is on Trump he's playing a double
game here on the one hand he's trying to
appease his base on the other hand he's
trying to signal to everybody that wink
wink nod nod I kind of like daca like
Republicans are split on this and you're
not seeing Trump come down in one
direction or another it's kind of
fascinating actually
Lindsey Graham for example he he sounds
exactly like a Democrat when he says to
dreamers you've done nothing wrong to
the DREAM Act population there are a lot
of people in the Republican side of the
aisle understand your dilemma and we
want to find a fair solution because you
you have done nothing wrong you came
here as children you've contributed to
society you have passed criminal
background checks you've demonstrated
your ability to be beneficial to the
country now in the future the only thing
that stands between you and sir
in your life is to Congress that cannot
be that reassuring okay the Trump is
trying to say is that it's Congress's
fault Congress should step in and fix
all of this and here's the thing the
Democrats agree Dianne Feinstein right
Democrat senator from California my
stage she's not a good senator but she
is a bright lady here's what she had to
say about Obama's executive amnesty she
said Congress should fix this a long
time ago daca was executive order legal
is what is the law of passage of
something I you know they're 10
attorneys general that are prepared to
sue I don't want to get into that the
point is daca is here and we've got
800,000 young people well your answer
indicating your answer indicates that
it's on shaky legal ground it is that's
why we need to pass a law okay she got
ripped up and down by her own party for
saying what is obviously true that daca
was unshaken legal ground and it's
really funny because you're seeing the
media go nuts right now look at the
uncertainty that's been created by daca
yes the uncertainty created by daca is
because President Obama decided to use
executive executive amnesty instead of
trying to get something through Congress
that's why there's a uncertainty excuse
me he asked all of these people to give
up all their information to the federal
government knowing full well that the
next president could very well strike
down daca he was just he had faith that
he could use these people as pawns the
Democrats have been using these people
as pawns for a long time and now
President Trump is using these people as
pawns as well it's really I find this
whole thing really distasteful I got to
be honest with you I find it really
distasteful because I think there's an
honest argument to be made for
deportation for a certain number of
people who are here illegally and not
benefiting the country as a whole again
on an individual level but Obama used
these people as pawns in 2012 to win
re-election he had control of the
Congress from 2008 to 2010 he did not do
a damn thing on any of this there's been
an easy pass
is an easy one he could have done this
in 2009 he didn't he chose not to and
then he used them as pawns in 2012 in
order to create this poison pill
situation for President Trump and now
President Trump in order to appease his
base is getting rid of daca just so long
as Congress will pass something else
I mean he's pledging that if Congress
doesn't pass something else he's going
to go right back to tackle or at least
will consider it is any of this good
policy no it's not good policy and it
shows you why partes
on both sides is destroying the debate
everyone on both sides basically agrees
on this issue even though they probably
shouldn't and yet they're bashing each
other's brains ins for this Kabuki
theater for their own base because the
Democratic base refuses to allow
Democrats to work with Trump and the
Republican base wants to pretend that
Trump is actually not in favor of daca
Wow yeah okay so when we come back I'm
going to explain to you a couple of
things I like in things I hate will do a
little bit of Bible talk but for that
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and become a subscriber for
$9.99 a month and you can get your
subscriptions who daily wire.com you can
become a subscriber you can see the rest
of the show live you can see the rest of
Andrew Clavin show live you can see the
rest of Michael Mosley's show live I'm
beyond Knowles's show a little bit later
today we're gonna do a little bit Q&A so
you should go over and check that out
and subscribe that'll be a lot of fun
plus you can be part of the mailbag on
Fridays very special mailbag this Friday
so I'm looking forward to that plus if
you want to get the annual subscription
$99 ears you get a discount from the
monthly plus you got this the greatest
of all possible vessels the leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler I've spoken
about it so highly there's really
nothing more for me to say other than
your life is incomplete if you don't
have this thing in your actual cupboard
you don't even have to use it you can
just gaze upon it and feel that your
life was worth something on your
deathbed that's really what this tumbler
is for go over for $99 the annual
subscription and check it out if you
just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud hit subscribe leave
us a review we always appreciate it we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so I want to get to some things I
like in some things I hate there's one
thing I hate there really is astonishing
today then I want to spend a little bit
of time on so let's start with a thing
that I like so the thing that I like
today is when I was in law school I
tried watching the show there's certain
shows where I don't know when I was
single and in law school and board it
was winter very often I would leave the
TV on in my room just because you want
some company right just just because you
want to hear some voices in the room
while you're reading an incredibly
boring law book and there are certain
shows you can't do that with like there
are certain shows particularly sitcoms
where you can sort of do that but
there's certain shows where if you don't
watch them closely because there's
actually a lot going on then you miss
what's going on you don't enjoy the show
fully so one of those shows was the wire
which I've recommended on the show
before when I first watched it I was
watching it sort of half distracted it's
a show you really have to concentrate on
in order to enjoy the show fully because
there's too much going on plot wise
another show that's like that is
Deadwood so when I first watched
Deadwood I really was not a big fan I
also couldn't get over the cursing
there's an enormous amount of cursing in
Deadwood it was sort of the way that it
was created I'm Claire's guy named David
Milch and they use the f-word and the
c-word and every every c-word actually
that is possible to use they use in that
show
they use all of these words on a really
frequent basis the reason
apparently that they used those show
that those words is because all of the
actual curse words that were used in the
Old West things like gall-darn they
sound funny to the modern ear so David
Milch wanted you to be shocked by the
language and how much people cursed back
then so he used modern curse words the
f-word believe it or not did not come
into common currency in the United
States and select the 1920s that's when
it became an actual common curse word
before that the f-word was not a thing
now it is amazing how it's become so
common that it's it's almost losing its
impact the f-word and people are gonna
move on to new and more egregiously
vulgar forms of language pretty soon in
any case Deadwood is all about the the
mining community of Deadwood South
Dakota this is back during the
post-civil war era of like shortly after
the Civil War and it's really well acted
a lot of the people who are stars on
Deadwood are known for the parts that
they played on Deadwood particularly I'm
thinking of the guy who plays the saloon
keep
why is his name escaping me now I hid in
McShane ian mcshane he's become a big
star because of dead what Timothy
Olyphant was the star of the show but
he's actually the weakest link in the
show in terms of acting Keith Carradine
it plays a Wild Bill plays Wild Bill
Hickok Wild Bill Hickok the guy who who
really is the best thing in the show and
was under appreciate as Brad Dourif Brad
zareff is one of the great actors of our
time okay so for people who don't know
Brad Dourif watch this show and then
watch Lord of the Rings and then watch
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest okay he
in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
he plays Billy Babbitt and is one of the
single greatest film performances ever
because if you read the book and then
you watch the movie he is the character
he is the I mean he and how it's a
character like no one else when he's
Grima Wormtongue he is Grima Wormtongue
and when he's the doc in this he is the
doc Brad Cerf is one of the most
underappreciated actors in modern
American history he really is terrific
he's only had these sort of bit parts
but he's amazing in any case the show is
really first-rate so you should go and
check out Deadwood here's a little bit
of the preview sons the cursing it is
definitely are too x-rated I would say
more r-rated than X but but here here's
a here is Deadwood
[Music]
there's a hell on the place it all could
get there's a lot of gold out here
something terrible's going on you're
gonna find out something now about
yourselves and your fellow man no one
gets out alive
okay there's so many terrific terrific
kind of character actors in this it
really is a showcase for all of these
character actors so you get people like
powers Boothe right who shows up as side
Tolliver you remember him as as curly
bill Brocius in Tombstone and he shows
up as the rival saloon keep the ian
mcshane really a terrific show and and
it has some depth to it as well so go
and check out Deadwood if you have a
taste for that kind of stuff if you are
if you're able to if you're able to
handle that kind of cursing and HBO
level violence and insects okay time for
some things that I hate all right so the
first thing that I hate today this is an
amazing amazing story according to
tablet magazine some people working with
the US Holocaust Memorial Museum had a
desire to whitewash former President
Barack Obama for his inaction via via
the the visa fees the the conflict in
Syria is according to Hank Baron at the
Daily wire they colored a new study
offered by the museum so it read quote a
variety of factors which were more or
less fixed made it very difficult from
the beginning for the u.s. government to
take effective action to prevent
atrocities in Syria even compared with
other challenging policy contexts they
were going to introduce this study on
September 11th it was supervised by
former Obama national security council
and intelligence officer Camus and
Cameron Hudson who now serves as
director of the Simon showed Center for
the Prevention of genocide according to
tablet magazine using computational
modeling in game theory methods as well
as interviews with experts and policy
makers the report asserted the greater
support for the anti-assad rebels and
u.s. strikes on the Assad regime after
the August 2013 Goethe chemical weapons
attack would not have reduced atrocities
in the country and might conceivably
have contributed to them so here's the
story the Obama administration a bunch
of Obama administration officials went
to the Holocaust Memorial Museum and
they made them write a report
they wrote a report retro actively
absolving retro actively absolving the
Obama administration of responsibility
for war atrocities in Syria this is the
equivalent of the FDR administration
former officials going to the Holocaust
Memorial Museum and saying can you write
a report saying that we had nothing that
if we hadn't bond that it wouldn't made
a difference if we had bombed the the
train lines to Auschwitz can you do that
for us because it might conceivably have
worsen things how do you even make that
call how do you make that call the whole
point of the Holocaust Memorial Museum
is that governments should do more to
prevent atrocities not to excuse
governments for atrocities they didn't
prevent Lee as Leon Wiesel tear who's
who's a literary critic and an author
he's a fellow at the Brookings Institute
he said shame on the Holocaust Museum he
blasted the museum for releasing an
allegedly scientific study that
justifies bystander ends bystander ISM
he added quote if I had the time I would
gin up a parody version of this that
will give us the computational modeling
algorithmic counterfactual analysis of
John J McCloy decision not to bomb the
Auschwitz ovens in 1944 I'm sure we
could concoct the effing algorithms for
that to Tablet noted since the outbreak
of the civil war in early 2011 the
Syrian dictator has repeatedly attacked
civilians with poison gas maintaining a
network of prison camps or as many as
60,000 people have been tortured
murdered and disappeared their bodies
dumped into crematoria and mass graves
even Abe Foxman who is a real leftist he
said I assume the leadership understands
and made a misstep I served three times
on the Holocaust Commission the
institution is very dear to my heart I
believe it's appropriate
indeed imperative for the museum to deal
with questions of genocide in
contemporary current events but in this
case several things are happening that
are problematic first the genocide isn't
over to more broadly I don't think it's
appropriate for the museum to issue this
kind of judgement that's beyond its
mandate so who works for the museum Ben
Rhodes Obama's former National Security
Advisor who is largely responsible for
the Iran deal ok Obama NSC alumni grant
Harris Anna cave
Daniel Benjamin all worked for Obama at
the NSC they are all on the Memorial
Council they were all appointed at the
end of Obama's tenure just disgusting
just disgusting and the museum is
offering the following message now by
people who wish to pursue peruse the
study says last week the US Holocaust
Memorial Museum Simon showed sensor for
the prevention of genocide released a
research study that examined several
decision points during the Syrian
conflict since her it's released a
number of people with whom we have
worked closely on Syria since the
conflicts outbreak have expressed
concerns with the study the museum has
decided to remove the study from its
website as we evaluate this feedback the
question is why they ran it in the first
place and the answer is because they're
a bunch of Democrats who wanted to
absolve other Democrats
seasons in a genocide that's what
happened here and just demonstrates how
fired Democrats are willing to go to
cover their own asses when it comes to
their complicity in genocide just
incredible stuff just incredible the
same revisionist history you know that
they're constantly accusing people on
the right of manufacturing news of
manufacturing history this is
manufactured news and manufactured
history using the guise of a Holocaust
Memorial in order to do it just gross
all the way through okay other things
that I hate so Linda Sarsour who of
course is the terror sympathizing
woman's march organizer who celebrated
all over the left because she wears a
hijab she has spent a lot of time
recently saying that as a person of
color this and as a person of color that
well he or she is a few years ago
explaining that she's actually just a
normal white girl and now she wears a
hijab so she's no longer normal white
girl when I wasn't wearing hijab I was
just some ordinary white girl from New
York City wearing hijab made you know
that I was Muslim
she was just an ordinary white girl you
understand but now she's a person of
color because she's thrown the hijab
this demonstrates that the left likes to
conflate activity with ethnic identity
okay I am technically a white person I
guess I mean Jews have been kind of
qualified as white and then not
qualified as white but for purposes of
the left I'm a white guy I'm still a
white guy even though I wear a yarmulke
it means I'm identifiable as a Jew in
the same way the hijab makes her
identifiable as a Muslim but the idea
this makes me a quote-unquote person of
color is just asinine and what this
really means is that for the left the
only real people of color are people who
are quote unquote victimized by the
broader society that's what they're
going for so when you slap on a hijab
suddenly you're a person of color
why not because you're actually a
personal color but because you're
victimized and this also means that if
you're a black person who's a Republican
if you are Larry elder if you are Walter
Williams if you're Thomas soul if you're
Clarence Thomas you're not an actual
black person because an actual black
person wouldn't act like that an actual
black part like Linda Sarsour is more
black than Clarence Thomas because Linda
Sarsour is a white person who wears a
hijab color in other words is just
another way for the left to say leftist
and that's what you see from Linda
Sarsour here she is a self-admitted not
person of color by this tape but she
calls herself a person of color all the
time okay final thing that I hate so the
Cleveland Browns have decided that they
are not going to a bunch of Cleveland
Browns who decided they're gonna kneel
for the national anthem and a bunch of
the cops said listen I'm not gonna go
there and hold the flag so that you can
disrespect the flag and Steven Naismith
who is sometimes right but it was more
often wrong he says that it's
disrespectful for the police officers to
refuse to hold the flag on the field in
response to the Browns protesting the
national anthem here's Steven Naismith
making the case with the execrable Max
Kellerman what's your reaction to the
Cleveland officers that they won't carry
flags now um I think the P I think
they're the ones disrespecting the flag
as opposed to the athletes for you to be
the benevolent association or anybody
else that then stands up and says we
will not support an organization who is
basically saying they agree with you but
they're supporting the rights of their
players because those players are
American citizens you are disrespecting
the flag more than the players are
because the players are exercising the
rights give it to them okay mrs. logic
you constantly hear from the left and is
really stupid I'm gonna defunk it really
fast okay so they constantly say things
like dissent is the highest form of
patriotism well depends on dissent from
what okay because if dissent is the
highest form of patriotism and
revolution is the highest form of
dissent then revolution is the highest
form of patriotism which is weird
because that would mean overthrowing the
government so that's not super patriotic
okay dissent is not always the highest
form of patriotism sometimes dissent is
the lowest form of patriotism the person
who burns the flag is not more patriotic
than the person who refuses to stand
there and hold the flag while you burn
it okay that's it that's it idiocy but
this is the sort of deconstruction that
you seek when you're attempting to
justify unjustifiable behavior it's the
players who are making a mockery of the
flag and if I decide not to go there and
participate in their mockery of the flag
good on me good on the cops
but again Steven Naismith is coming to
this with a pre-arranged conception of
who's right and who's wrong the people
who are kneeling are right and justified
and therefore anyone who impedes their
efforts must be wrong okay time for it
to Wednesday so a time for a little bit
of quick Bible talk so this week the
portion of the of the profits that we
read in the Jewish community because
every week we read a portion of the
profits as well as a portion from the
Torah is from the Book of Isaiah
they're a bunch of different sections
from Isaiah that we
read in the lead up to the high howl of
the High Holy Days Rosh Hashanah is
coming up in like two and a half weeks I
think
and then Yom Kippur is coming up right
after that so these are considered the
days of atonement for Jews this month is
the days of atonement technically are
the ten days between Rosh Hashanah and
Yom Kippur but these are the month
beforehand is considered a time for
repentance and and so we like to read
about the uplift of repentance returning
to God and what you get when you return
to God so here is from Isaiah chapter 60
19 through 21 you shall no longer have
the Sun for light by day and for
brightness the moon shall not give you
light but the Lord shall be for you an
everlasting light and your God for your
glory your son shall no longer set and
either your moon shall be gathered in
for the Lord shall be to you and
everlasting light and the days of your
mourning shall be completed and your
people all of them righteous shall
inherit the land forever a scion of my
planting the work of my hands in which I
will glory the point that I want to make
here is that we live in a very
naturalistic world we live in very
materialist conception of reality in the
last 200 years really since probably
David Hume the the deconstruction of the
notion that nature is part and parcel of
God has taken on rather sinister aspects
with regard to religion this notion that
nature is is a is a living rebuke to God
that there's always a naturalistic
explanation for everything's you don't
need God God is an unnecessary
hypothesis as a philosopher once put it
to Napoleon well what this is saying in
Isaiah is that really nature is a mask
nature is a mask we live in a natural
materialistic world and it's impossible
for us to detect anything logically
beyond that beyond that natural world
you can you can come up with rationales
but there's no proof for it and so
because we live in this materialistic
world we think that's all there is what
this is saying in Isaiah is that the
real light is the light of God that all
of the rest of this these are just
manifestations of God's nature that he's
created for you a world mask as rabbi
akiva tats puts it but when it comes
down to what is real in the universe
there is something beyond there is
something outside of Plato's cave there
is something that is unseeable
but exists beyond the light and that
light that true light infuses the nature
with which we deal so there's the Sun
and for light by day and the moon that
we would rely upon but in the end if
we're not relying on God then we're
living in a universe devoid of meaning
and
it's not the Sun thing she relied and
not the moon you should rely on but the
everlasting light of God to infuse the
entire universe with meaning and in the
end of days when there is repentance
then that mask will fall away and we'll
all see clearly that nature as beautiful
it is it as it is the systems that God
created for us to live in they were
created by a master hand and that master
hand has infused all of it with a
meaning that makes your life worth
living that's what Isaiah is saying here
okay
we'll be back here tomorrow we'll give
you the update on daca and everything
else plus we'll give you the update on
this this hurricane that's now headed
from Florida a bad year for hurricanes
in the United States we'll talk about
all of that i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]